all right guys here it is gamespot's III
flip man all right looks a little bigger
than last year's can I bring my fancy
lobby chair account when you talk about
video games on the internet without my
fancy lobby chair wait who's this area
over here for oh that's really a kind of
funny guys are gonna be sitting oh nice
wait what dude they're gonna eat all of
our poop yeah I mean they are right now
you have any wings this June watch the
guys from kind of funny team up with
gamespot for the best III coverage of
all time watch the game spot stage for
demos of all the latest titles announced
at e3 2015 and watch the kind of funny
stage to watch the guys hang out with
the biggest names on the internet to
talk about everything happening at the
show that's two shows two streams
broadcast directly from the e3 show
floor into your eyeballs this coming
June check it out LA Convention Center
am i right things are happening I hope
they announce full at four they don't
man [ __ ] them
you